new york's a tough city to live in uh it
always has been
hearing
the old saying if you can make it here
you can make it anywhere i think
because the birds have made it here i
mean they've endured this far
my name is steve baldwin and i've been
tracking the wild pirates of brooklyn
for about 10 years now those two look
sort of frisky it's not really that
mating season but
my episode of menace
the monk parakeet native to argentina
and as far as we know something happened
at kennedy airport in 1967 or 1968. it
appears that a crate full of parrots
arrived from argentina something went
wrong a bunch of them escaped they came
to brooklyn college right here
we've got an incredible cast of parrots
here today
one two three four
they're smaller than a pigeon but larger
than a sparrow
they're the only kind of parrots that
build these freestanding structures
these nests can get up to the size of
small cars it's methodical work it's
twig after twig after twig parrots are
sort of the primates of the bird world
they're smart they're communicative they
eat almost anything that's available to
them so they're perfectly set up really
to thrive in a place like brooklyn uh
even though it's not where they came
from they've adapted extremely well
you have to i think have a certain fiber
of steel to make it in this town and i
think the parrots have those qualities